[Musique]
une
bonjour je m'appelle patrick des school
je suis arrivé à chinon en 91 où on a
repris un restaurant de plateau de
première pour faire un restaurant queue
de poisson gastronomique donc depuis
j'ai commencé le métier on va dire
14 15 ans où j'ai commencé chez un de
mes tontons qui était cuisinier en
vendée et j'ai découvert la cuisine chez
lui et après à 15 ans et demi j'ai
commencé par un apprentissage dans le
loir et cher
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui on va réaliser une
recette de coquilles saint-jacques
accompagné d'un riz vénéré donc savez un
riz qu'on va cuire à basse température
au four vapeur est accompagné d'un jus
iodé donc un julio des on va prendre
soin d'une moule ou un jus de coke
une marée une marinière qu'on va monter
au beurre donc c'est une chose très
simple qu'on peut faire à la maison et
qui est facile à réaliser
donc là on va commencer par le snack et
les petits champignons les revenir
légèrement un prêt en haute côte
ensuite on va préparer notre petite
chose donc on va mettre un petit peu de
jus de coquillages
donc on va monter au beurre donc là on
fait une cuisine gourmande ans et on y
va donc les coquilles saint-jacques donc
on a nettoyé donc la manne on va les
couper en deux parce qu'on va les cuire
à l'unilatérale donc c'est un produit
qui demande peu de cuisson juste une
légère coloration
voilà on va mettre quelques fèves de
soja quelques baies de goji pour la
couleur maintenant on va mettre notre
vénéré maintenant on va pouvoir disposer
nos coquilles saint jacques
on va rajouter notre purée de patates 12
fumarate et que petit champignon par
dessus maintenant on va pouvoir des
cercles et tout doucement et ajouté
notre sauce voilà lucas déguster
[Musique]
on